[Music]
a tech firm
will pay you
280 000 to have your face imprinted on
robots
who's down i'm down what the [ __ ] i mean
that's easy money 180
for what yeah we didn't hit the peak of
the bull run yet come on dude that's
going back into is it is it a sex robot
because it's not a sex it's not a sex
robot i would definitely because robust
there has to be robots that get
neglected too so i would definitely
volunteer
they buy you to not pay attention to you
you gotta look like brad pitt probably
why that guy looks like he's gone
that robot that sex robot looked too
sassy that would look like yeah all
right
that look that robot looks skeptical
about that the [ __ ] unbelievable
robot is like
that's the that's the girl's face i want
on my sex robot so after i come she's
just like
she's like yeah sure
two minutes yeah a robot that's program
[ __ ] cynical bot dude yeah why is
that face like look at the face like the
face is so like skeptical he's making
fun of you dude skip the bot and his
arms are always like this
it won't take any commands because it's
always like i know
i listen to you could i do it for a
hundred
[Laughter]
yeah why 280 like so it's a tech company
is gearing up to launch a new line of
human looking robots but they want to
they want them to have a friendly face
also that that face ain't foreign
it's hard to find a friendly face you
gotta get a better one and like 280
sounds like they scrounged up money to
get 280. like yeah
they couldn't do 300.
just 280 y'all what about 250 that's too
low all right all i got was 280. okay
for licensing your face well probably
could just make a range of computer
generated created faces they're looking
for actual humans to lend their features
for the newest batch of machines can i
when can i sign up i do this
what does it mean that you no longer own
your face that's fine you gotta have my
face you won't do it for 10 bucks then
you can't be in a marvel movie bro
that's fine i'm not gonna own a mansion
in oklahoma that's true
but remember let me let me let me let me
actually read where they say they're
willing to pay this amount right
to the special someone to hand over the
rights to their face so it's not just
about putting your face
onto a robot it's handing over the
rights to your face in terms of like
digital like
they own the rice they're gonna make my
face at nft
yeah essentially they don't make your
face anything but basically if you're if
you're on instagram and it's a sponsored
page you won't be able to get any money
from for it they they'll get the money
or if it's fine or if you post a picture
of yourself they can copyright claim you
now that's cool
just be a [ __ ] match to dj for the
rest of your life yeah dude i would love
to be dead mouse
what if you do this and with the portion
of the money you get plastic surgery so
you just don't look like you're before
yourself
yeah you got a new face make one eye
smaller
[Laughter]
oh what the [ __ ]
robo see
yo they look scary dude what's the
purpose of these robots anyway
why couldn't they make them attractive
because then they would compete with
their sex doll division
[Music]
because you know the sex doll robotic
people they're probably the the leaders
yeah yeah that's true this is what they
got bro wow these are the mouth moves
why do they gotta make them look like a
40 year old smoker they look like
hostages those those are some you know
dude this guy looks like
you know that robot looks like he's
about to have a stroke yeah
without that the girl robot like look
like she's ready yeah she's ready she's
ready to go clearly they borrowed that
from the sex doll division and we need
some lips the company said it's hunchy
for a kind and friendly face appearance
but they will be open to applications
from people of all races and genders
though you'll have to be over the age of
25. promobot is hoping to launch their
robots in hotels shopping centers and
airports in north america and the middle
east from 2023 you know what that
reminds me of the wax museum it feels
like that or like um you know when they
have those like i recently went to this
um
it's kind of like this weird
uh history telling
thing
they have all these like what do you
call them like they're not puppets but
they're like full life figurines
and then um
oh that's [ __ ] crazy but it's like
it's hella janky right it's in monterey
bay and then you're going and it's the
history of monterey bay and then
the figures look [ __ ] weird man it's
like they tell the whole story of like
when the natives were there and then the
whole [ __ ] oyster diving industry or
whatever and
yeah it looks like that like those kind
of like yeah those dead robots and [ __ ]
what are they gonna do at airports
service automated service so think about
like um what were we just talking about
just earlier where uh swallowing yeah
yeah
yeah so that's that's what they're going
to be talking about like call centers or
random [ __ ] um anyways point is uh you
know like you can't even uh do tech
support customer service and a lot of
different major corporations you don't
even like talk to real human like
twitter was that was it was that what we
were talking about coinbase
right it's not even like real people
yeah working it's all automated it's all
response so like putting an actual
robotic face in those kind of like
customer service i hope to thank god
they don't have robots for the customer
service can be so much worse they
already know
that pisses me off because i'm like
where's a human you're a [ __ ] billion
dollar company whereas a human being
that i got i got to fix this [ __ ] with
yeah did you guys catch the racism
though in this i said we're looking for
friendly faces but we're also looking
for people of all races
wow the butt so what they're saying is
is that we want white people
but but
black people are okay too we'll look at
your application we'll take the eight
we'll take the angry asian grandpa yeah
we'll take you know diversity is cool
for us you know we'll take the sad
mexican you know we'll we'll do that
that's the
same we want friendly faces but
other races are okay too yeah for now
why don't you just say you want white
people
we want the friendly white face
you guys seen uh the progressive
commercial lady
flow have you guys seen like the deep
fake stuff yeah yeah uh like the tom
cruise guy and all that stuff right like
the fake technology but like
we're definitely moving into a uh
normalized world technologically
speaking where like that is going to
become more so
we're gonna find that on like phone apps
as like regular apps soon we're gonna
like um people are just gonna be able to
kind of like jack faces and voice and
like movement features or whatever right
now we're seeing it on [ __ ] like porn
models and random advertisements and
stuff but like what do you think is
really going to happen in the metaverse
near future you know what i'm saying you
sign the rights off to your face
like literally you can walk into the
[ __ ] metaverse and see somebody
that's you and you don't have the rights
to that you know what i'm saying like
that's kind of like where we can go
so i say we [ __ ] got to take
advantage of that [ __ ] now you know what
i'm saying so for your face for 280 g's
maybe maybe
maybe your face is worth more i think
i love you 300 no one else believes that
yeah everybody [ __ ] looked at me
steve if steve was here he would have
been like [ __ ] you nick
[ __ ] and see he's not here because he's
worth more than 280 yeah
that's why he's not in jk and going on
that's why he's gone dude
he's never coming back we need to get
him back for the diversity card dude we
need a white guy here you mean a
friendly face friendly family friendly
very friendly face but we're also
excited all races
we are we're we'll think about it
i would love it if someone made a deep
fake of me like in like a sex video so
then i could finally see what i look
like having sex that'd be amazing
as both people yeah i'd be like
yeah yeah he fixed him as the chick
i've always wanted to see myself get
[ __ ] by myself that's amazing great
the girl filter thingy
do you guys like where everything's
going with all the crazy you know i just
the advancement of technology and it's
scary i don't know yet because it's not
it's a theory it's like not really in
action yet you know it's like it's the
very early stages yeah you know google
they they can automate voices to where
it sounds like humans yeah so people
they uh they order pizza it's not like a
regular person so when they uh
publicized it people immediately
complained wait a minute it doesn't
sound like a robot no no you can't do
that because then that means whoever has
that program can call someone and fake
them out into handing over money so then
google said okay we're going to stop
this which they didn't probably yeah and
then they use their now their voices
some more robotic
oh wow they went backwards a little bit
yeah but i'm sure they're still
progressing to where um it's so
basically the intonations of a person
the pauses all it sounds like a regular
person yeah because when you listen to
some audio books or whatever sometimes
you're like man this is a [ __ ] robot
it sounds weird yeah or someone from the
50s they they already have enough info
to fully replicate our image or in 3d
and our voices in intonation and style
already like
like who has iphones
you know iphones you can change the
accent of siri yeah so they had before
they had australian and british now they
have singaporean they have indian they
have a singaporean
singaporean sounds a little bit
indian is awesome so the girl indian
just sounds like a little bit british
but the guy uh
indian accent is like the stereotypical
guy indian accent so i told my friends
like dude that's racist
for indians it's not racist because
that's how they learn english yeah we
don't like for korean people we don't
teach
they don't teach english incorrectly to
for the queen accent they try to do
american accent but in india that's how
they teach english all the characters so
for them it's not racist to hear it so
they have it on their iphone i always
thought i'd be dope to have an app that
could change the accents to like korean
accent chinese zacks and japanese that'd
be awesome so you're saying in india if
somebody's like really no no really
that's how they learn it and i only
learned that because this indian girl
told me because i asked her i go hey
like what's your first language she was
english i go no really like what's your
first language because she has an accent
how is english your first language when
you speak with an accent like that you
know she goes no this is how we learn
english oh because they're colonized by
england yeah that's why that's the
english thing so they don't look at it
as like a detriment to them whereas like
asians the big three we look at it as
like we want to hide we want to
eliminate yeah but like for them they're
just like no this is our axis well
that's like singaporean english yeah
that's like they're english yeah yeah
it's very hodgepodge
it's very and so their acceptance is
very different than ours like ours as
soon as we hear someone do actually we
get offended we're taught to get
offended immediately because we're
trying to be white used exactly
or black yeah either one
we'll take both of them friendly or
black
it's only one of the two
i thought that was interesting that is
hella interesting
so i have mine set on indian
it's awesome so the directions are all
indian accent like you know let me make
a number one [ __ ] left
one [ __ ] and it's program
so they read they read all the street
signs oh sun ways when like kevin hart
does it he only does left right goes
straight because he can't program his
voice to do all the different street
names but on the indian accent it's
programmed to do all the streaming so he
reads all the street names
and he just turn the left turn right
damn that's dope awesome i'm a twitch
man indian so i think like in the future
they're gonna have the ability to be
like with unique voices like you know
like kevin hart or morgan freeman to do
all the directions we're gonna be able
to do that they need to do pacquiao
pacquiao siri
how would pacquiao
go um i think maybe you go left here and
it's always too late yeah yeah oh sorry
it's too late where do i go yeah um i
think maybe
maybe
i decided
around
[Music]